ce n'est pas un coup d'État militaire
c'est la justice qui est en marche voilà
les mots de yefghani Prigogine le chef
du groupe paramilitaire Wagner a annoncé
être rentré en rébellion ouverte contre
le commandement militaire russe ses
forces sont entrées en Russie aurait
pris et ont pris Rostov sur le don c'est
près de la frontière
ukrainienne cela sans un coup de feu
selon le chef du groupe paramilitaire le
but également vous la percevez sur cette
carte remontée vers Moscou voici le
trajet supposé des troubles du groupe
Wagner alors difficile de dire s'il
s'agit d'une progression ou s'il y avait
déjà des membres de cette de ce groupe
qui était présent dans les régions que
vous voyez apparaître sur cette carte
l'aublace de voroneige notamment a fait
état de combat celui de lipette qui est
à peine à 400 km de Moscou invité les
habitants à rester chez eux et celui de
Kaluga notamment qui est à proximité
immédiate de Moscou à Moscou justement
les autorités se préparent à cette
arrivée très probable des troupes de
Wagner le maire de la ville évoque une
situation difficile selon lui à décréter
la journée de lundi chômé il invite
également les Moscovites à limiter leur
déplacement et pour évoquer c'est très
Bellion notre chroniqueur internationale
je vous disais en titre est avec nous en
plateau Bruno Darro bonjour Bruno
bonjour Antoine à Bruno avancé des
troupes du des troupes de Wagner tout au
long de la de la journée on a suivi sur
notre antenne à Moscou le maire je le
disais évoque une situation difficile
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer Bruno selon
vous
écoutez qu'est-ce qui va se passer c'est
c'est difficile à dire ce qui est sûr
c'est que il y a une remontée des
miliciens Wagner sur Moscou alors
effectivement on peut voir sur la carte
que certainement certaines unités sont
partis peut-être de Rostov sur le nom
sur le don mais il y avait déjà
des unités un peu partout en territoire
russe notamment voilà notamment à
véronech quoi exactement le parcours qui
a été emprunté mais quoi qu'il en soit
on assiste depuis plusieurs heures à
cette remontée sans à vous de résistance
il y a eu apparemment quand même
l'intervention de d'hélicoptère de
l'aviation russe mais franchement côté
terrestre il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de
résistance alors ça peut peut-être
s'expliquer si voilà si on revoit la
carte par le fait que
l'essentiel en fait des troupes russes
se trouvent actuellement vous voyez dans
voilà dans ce quasi demi cercle ou
carrément évidemment en Ukraine en train
de combattre l'armée ukrainienne et que
les forces c'est ça qui va être
intéressant à observe intéressant oui il
y a observer dans les prochaines heures
après autour de Moscou c'est plutôt des
des unités de ce qu'on appelle la garde
nationale qui relis militaire d'une
certaine manière qui regroupe plusieurs
plusieurs unités elles-mêmes dont
l'unité d'ailleurs chargé de de protéger
les personnalités dont Vladimir Poutine
mais sur le sur le trajet là quand
emprunté le la ministre Wagner il y a eu
assez peu visiblement
de résistance des forces terrestres ou
alors il y a eu une forme de d'empathie
et de laisser faire laisser passer de la
part de ces unités militaires qui
répondrai ainsi à l'appel de yefghani
prigogne vis-à-vis des militaires parce
que ce que dit prigogi en fait ce qu'il
dénonce c'est les clowns comme il les
appelle
shoego donc le Sergio le ministre de la
Défense et le chef d'état-major Valérie
garacimov qui dirigerait très mal selon
lui la guerre en Ukraine mais Prigogine
dit comme vous l'avez signalé Antoine
moi je suis pas là pour faire un coup
d'état je suis là pour en quelque sorte
dégager ces deux personnalités nocives
et incompétentes mais j'appelle au
contraire les militaires à me rejoindre
et il a parce que évidemment même si la
censure est importante en Russie les
réseaux sociaux fonctionnent quand même
et brigogine est un as de cette
communication façon 2023 et donc est
toujours en scène parmi ces hommes sur
le terrain etc pas comme ces planqués en
quelque sorte qui sont loin du champ de
bataille donc il est quand même assez
populaire sans doute parmi de nombreux
de nombreux soldats peut-être même
gendarmes ou policiers quoi qu'il en
soit on peut on ne peut que constater
qu'à leur où on se parle et bien
les troupes en quelque sorte de yefghani
Prigogine sont du côté de lippiette
peut-être même selon certaines
informations se rapprocheraient-elles de
Kaluga et vous voyez que là on est
simplement à 80 centimètres de Moscou
donc à Moscou du coup preuve de la
colonne nervosité des autorités
l'état anti-terroriste a été décrété
notamment avec la mise en place de
Checkpoint à l'entrée de la banlieue
après Moscou c'est une ville c'est une
ville énorme et la question qui se pose
ensuite c'est que va faire gagner
une fois qu'il arrive à Moscou quel est
quel est son objectif on peut se dire
qu'en fait il a pris Rostov sur le don
parce que en principe il y avait présent
là-bas parce que c'est le quartier
général opérationnel des opérations
russes pour l'Ukraine le général Valérie
guérinov chef d'état-major bon
visiblement il était pas là et puis
l'autre qui est quand même dans la ligne
de mire de prix gaugine c'est goût qui
lui est à Moscou ministère de la défense
mais après est-ce qu'il y aura une
confrontation est-ce qu'on va assister
dans les prochaines heures peut-être à
des tirs dans la capitale ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas à exclure ce n'est pas à
exclure est-ce que de manière plus
générale vous l'avez un petit peu évoqué
Bruno est-ce que
if Beni yefghani Prigogine vous avez
évoqué la la manière dont il a repris
prix resto sur le nom sans quasiment un
coup de feu la relative passivité de
l'armée russe est-ce que on peut dire
qu'il a bénéficié de d'une forme de
complicité au sein de l'appareil d'État
russe il y avait gagné Prigogine selon
vous écoutez ça semble relativement
probable on va rester prudent parce que
encore une fois on n'a pas
bien évidemment beaucoup d'informations
ce qui est sûr pour remettre un peu en
contexte si vous voulez
les relations de la ministre Wagner avec
effectivement shoyu et Gira simov était
exécrable depuis des mois il y a eu sans
doute aussi la décision de Poutine de
valides de Vladimir Poutine de valider
la demande de shoyu que toutes les
milices signent un contrat avec le
ministère de la Défense l'objectif
c'était quoi c'était que le ministère de
la Défense reprennent la main sur ces
milices et notamment sur Wagner et ça
pour Wagner ça a été et pour prix
gaugine ça a été vraiment la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase ou la
menace qu'il a ressentie soit de se
faire complètement mettre de côté et lui
perdre son pouvoir parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de questions de pouvoir et
d'argent aussi dans ses affaires soit
d'être obligé de faire allégeance à
cette personnalité qu'il exécre alors de
là sans doute ça sa décision de passer
un lac de franchir du Rubicon parce
qu'il y avait quand même dans la
décision que les milices devaient passer
un contrat que le ministère de la
Défense une un deadline une date limite
qui était au 1er juillet nous sommes le
24 juin il fallait un moment ou un autre
agir après il y avait gagné prigogne
malgré ça voilà quand on le voit comme
ça il est il parle beaucoup il est assez
virulent voir grossier etc mais en fait
c'est aussi un homme d'affaires il ne
fait pas les choses n'importe comment
donc sans doute pour répondre essayez de
répondre à votre question sans doute
bénéficie-t-il de certains relais au
sein de l'état-major russe et peut-être
au sein des oligarques un mot également
vous l'avez dit Bruno prigogni il a
longtemps bénéficié des faveurs du
Kremlin et de Vladimir Poutine c'est
dans une certaine manière un peu sa
créature il l'a fait monter et gagner
Pringy on est souvent c'est l'ancien
cuisinier de Vladimir Vladimir Poutine
est-ce que d'une certaine manière on
peut dire que la marionnette de Vladimir
Poutine a coupé ses films maintenant oui
c'est un peu ce qui se passe la créature
échoppe à son créateur parce que il faut
reconnaître que depuis 2014 date à
laquelle privilégi n'a créé cette milice
au début elle a rempli beaucoup de
services pour le compte de l'Etat russe
d'abord en Syrie
parmi notamment la prise de Palmyre donc
elle a joué un rôle très important et
puis ensuite en Afrique et en
particulier en République centrafricaine
donc ça permettait à Moscou si vous
voulez de de faire faire le sale boulot
de mener ce que Moscou appelle cette
guerre hybride comme ça par une milice
qui était à l'époque en quelque sorte
dissimulé il y avait gagné prigogi ne
disait pas qu'il était pas trop du
ministre etc il a fait son coming out en
quelque sorte en septembre dernier donc
Moscou comme ça disait Benoît nous on y
est pour rien oui c'est des mercenaires
on a aucun contact avec eux c'était
complètement faux il était soutenu par
les par les par le FSB par les
renseignements militaires par le guerou
donc forcément il y avait aussi des des
contacts entre frigogines et ces gens-là
donc on sait qu'il a certaines amitiés
par exemple avec le général sur viking
qui était en Syrie et qui aujourd'hui
est à ceux qui dirige les opérations
militaires en Ukraine donc à l'heure où
on se parle on ne sait pas tout si
Prigogine a lancé cet acte qui paraît un
peu fou de de défiance sans avoir
quelques appuis c'est qu'il est c'est
qu'il est suicidaire ça ne paraît pas
trop être le genre de l'homme mais il a
eu des garanties
ça paraît le plus plausible évidemment
on en a pas là on en a pas la preuve
mais sinon ce qu'il fait là et
littéralement suicidaire quand même
merci beaucoup Bruno pour toutes ces
explications